Speaker 1: Guys, remember how after the 2020
election, Donald Trump never really admitted
that he lost and he never really conceded.
But he eventually started saying things like
the next administration.
And we were kind of like, that's kind of a
concession.
And he said to Sean Hannity last week, we
didn't win.
And we said, oh, it's kind of Trump admitting
that he didn't win.
Trump has now resurfaced in a completely laughable,
embarrassing and pathetic excuse for an interview
on a program called Just the News on a channel,
I guess, called Real America's Voice.
I don't know what any of this stuff is to
tell the interviewer, David Brody, that Trump
never admitted defeat and that Trump still
has not conceded the 2020 election.
It has to be seen to be believed.
And that is exactly what we are going to do.
Here is the first clip.
Listen to this insanity.
I want to
Speaker 3: start with something you told Sean
Hannity last week.
The headlines were about how you admitted
defeat in the twenty twenty election when
you said we didn't win.
Is that an accurate headline?
Did you admit defeat?
I just want to understand that.
Speaker 4: No, I never admitted defeat, by
the way,
Speaker 1: how bad this is.
No, I never admitted defeat
Speaker 4: of a lot of things happening right
now.
I think that that was an election that was
I don't think you have to do is read the newspapers
and see what's coming out now.
You know, I never know where it is.
I can see they have not can see.
Speaker 1: So there is Trump saying, I have
not conceded and I have not admitted defeat.
Now, remember, conceding defeat is not legally
relevant and it's not legally binding in any
way.
This is how Trump strings along his ignorant
followers.
Oh, wow.
Did you.
That was a signal Trump didn't technically
admit defeat.
Something's coming.
He hasn't conceded.
Conceding is legally irrelevant.
It's electorally irrelevant.
It's a formality that normal adult politicians
engage in when they've lost, but it is legally
meaningless.
And Trump is also straight up lying.
He said to Hannity, we didn't win.
He wildly said, we'll see what happens with
that, alluding to this return to office in
August.
But this is just last week.
Remember this, guys?
Speaker 2: You ever considered it and are
you considering it?
Speaker 4: Well, I am.
And frankly, if you think of it, that's what
I've been doing and talking about for a long
time.
And I guess that's why we got them by surprise.
And 16 and 20, we did much better than we
did in 16.
And shockingly, we were supposed to win easily
and 64 million votes and we got 75 million
votes and we didn't win, but we didn't win
on that whole thing.
Speaker 1: But we'll see what happens on that.
Trump said it now.
He denies saying it.
He lies all the time period and he now plays
coy with the term concession.
And it's all just a joke.
This entire interview was bonkers.
Trump continues to blame Mike Pence for accepting
the twenty twenty election results as if he
had a choice.
Right.
He's still disappointed in Pence.
Speaker 3: I don't want to listen to The New
York Times.
They always like to write about the relationship
between you and Mike Pence.
Can you explain that to us right now?
There's a portion of the Magor crowd.
You know, the deal.
They're never going to forgive the vice president
for not kicking those certain disputed election
results back to state legislatures.
What's your what's your take on Mike Pence
and and how what's the relationship like?
Speaker 4: Well, I've always liked.
And I'm very disappointed that he didn't send
it back to the legislatures when you have
more votes than you have voters in some cases.
Now, that's not true.
Speaker 1: You didn't have more votes than
voters.
And again, disappointed Pence couldn't do
anything.
Pence couldn't do anything.
And Trump's own followers don't know that.
They now heckle Pence as traitor and unpatriotic
and whatever else,
Speaker 4: when you have the kind of things
that are that were known in many cases, they
were known then.
But they're certainly getting better and better
known now.
Now, I was disappointed that he didn't send
it back.
I felt he had the right to send it back and
he should have sent it back.
Speaker 1: He is completely wrong.
Pence had no ability to do anything.
He could have tried some stuff that would
have been historically humiliating.
He really couldn't do anything.
But it doesn't matter in the world of Trump.
Speaker 4: That's my opinion.
And I think if he did, I think those legislators
look at Pennsylvania now, look at look at
Georgia, look at Arizona and look at others.
They're all now looking at what happened during
that election
Speaker 1: and nothing will come of it.
Trump continues to string his followers along.
Nothing will come of these fake audits.
Speaker 4: I think you would have found that
you might very well have a different president
right now.
Speaker 1: You would not.
You would not.
What you would have would be an even more
humiliated former vice president and former
president and Trump.
That's what you would have.
But Pence couldn't do anything about it.
Trump also asked about 2020 for his comments
there.
Sort of interesting
Speaker 3: on twenty twenty four, by the way,
here, here's my take and I'm curious to get
your take.
Would it be accurate to say that if a super
majority of the candidates that you're supporting
right now, if they win in the midterms and
Republicans take back the House and the Senate,
that would make it more likely that you would
run at that point?
Is that true?
What do you think?
Speaker 4: No, I don't think so, but I think
that's what is going to happen.
Speaker 1: Now, this is super interesting.
Trump is asked, are you more likely to run
if the people you support in 22 do well?
And Trump says, no, it's the wrong question
and the right question shouldn't even be asked
of Trump because he'll just lie.
The right question is, are you more likely
to win if the people you support in 22 do
well?
And that's ultimately what this hinges on
and hangs on.
And that's what we've been talking about.
Trump needs to successfully have his coalition,
the Catherines and the BOBERT and the majority
of the Greens.
They need to do well in 2022 to bolster Trump
for 24.
I think Trump may well run regardless of whether
he does well in twenty two, but his chances
will be greatly diminished if the people he
supports don't win in the midterm election.
Let's continue.
Speaker 4: My endorsements have meant a lot,
right?
Almost undefeated, very close to undefeated.
Speaker 1: Understand that with Trump at the
helm of the Republican ship, they lost the
House in twenty eighteen.
They lost the Senate in 2020 and they lost
the White House in 2020.
Trump undefeated.
That's wrong in a literal sense.
But the spirit of what he's saying, he's been,
in a sense, a disaster for the Republican
Party.
They've lost everything,
Speaker 4: hundreds and hundreds of endorsements,
people when Salinas said the Republican Party
chair in North Carolina and in Georgia.
Speaker 1: And, you know, a lot of these are
meaningless endorsements where there's really
not anybody running or there's one real candidate
and it's often an incumbent.
And to say that Trump's endorsement has any
value there, that's really a stretch places.
Speaker 4: We just had congressional candidates,
but I mean, hundreds of endorsements.
And our record is, I think, unmatched anywhere
at any time.
So we're going to gain the majority first.
And I think it would be I think it's very
important that we do that.
I don't know that would have any impact on
my decision.
Speaker 1: However, that may be true.
It may not impact Trump's decision, but it
definitely impacts his viability.
Just a little bit more of this have that
Speaker 3: impact on your decision.
What's going through your mind on that?
A lot of people want to know.
Speaker 4: Well, I think I'm just looking
at what's going on.
I'm very unhappy with what's going on.
And I look at the border where people are
coming in by the millions.
It's going to be by the millions very soon.
Speaker 1: So notice that how he slips, that
they're coming in by the millions.
He knows that that's not really true.
So he says soon it's going to be made by the
millions.
And of course, it's not.
Speaker 4: It already is.
Oh, look, it's got other things how our country
is really.
It's America.
Last I was America.
First I look at it and I see what's happening
and I'm not happy about it's so
Speaker 1: just meaningless drivel.
As I've told you before, the standing and
reputation of the United States around the
world was greatly diminished under Donald
Trump.
It's been greatly bolstered early in Joe Biden's
presidency.
Doesn't mean Biden's perfect, doesn't mean
Biden is even great on policy.
It's just the reputation of the United States
around the world.
So just about every aspect of this completely
backwards during the interview.
But the key point there, Trump again playing
coy.
I did.
Concede, I didn't concede when the reality
is the concession is unnecessary and it's
just another way to continue stringing along
his low information voters into saying, well,
maybe he will come back because technically
he didn't concede much more of this stuff
is to be expected as we get closer and closer
to the 2022 midterms and Trump needs to put
some winds up
on
the board.